Hello, and welcome to another bonus episode of how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎收听《老爸老妈的浪漫史》制作揭秘的又一期加更节目。
We are calling these bonus episodes general questions, general questions.
我们把这些加更节目叫做“常规问题”，常规问题。
Still makes me laugh.
这还是让我觉得很好笑。
I'm here as always with my dear friend and how I met your mother co-creator, Craig Thomas.
和往常一样，我的身旁坐着我的挚友、《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的联合创作者克雷格·托马斯。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
It's great to be here.
很高兴能来到这里。
It's been a minute.
好久不见了。
We took a little break in a few weeks and we have our lovely producer, Alec Lev, and I've never called you lovely, and I'm never going to do it again, so just try it.
我们休息了几周，然后我们有可爱的制片人阿莱克·莱夫——我从来没叫过你可爱，而且我以后也不会再叫了，所以你就享受这一次吧。
He's lovely.
他很可爱。
Lovely.
可爱。
I'm lovely producer.
我是可爱的制片人。
Nailed it.
说得太对了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Well, we are answering all your questions from episode five of How I Met Your Mother, which is called Okay Awesome, written by Chris Harris.
那么，我们要回答大家关于《老爸老妈的浪漫史》第五集的所有问题，那一集叫《绝妙好局》，由克里斯·哈里斯编剧。
We did a deep dive recently into the episode.
我们最近深入探讨了那一集。
This is the one where the gang goes to the nightclub and no one can hear anyone.
这一集讲的是主角团去夜店，结果谁也听不清别人说话。
So half the episode subtitled in a genius move and Marshall and Lily are escaping from their wine and cheese boring adult party to join them.
所以这集有一半都有字幕，真是个绝妙的举动，马修和莉莉则逃离了他们那场无聊的红酒奶酪成人派对来加入他们。
So Alec, tell us what happened.
阿莱克，跟我们讲讲情况吧。
What was the viewer listener male like?
观众和听众的来信情况怎么样？
We got lots of questions as we have every time through Instagram.
我们收到了很多问题，就像之前每一次在Instagram上收到的一样。
I'm going to ask this one, but then I'm going to broaden out a little bit.
我要先问这个，但随后我会稍微拓展一下。
Sam underscore Ashwood says was Marshall's dance outlined in the script or mostly ad lib during filming love the show Thank you for the endless hours of entertainment now on my well a big number.
网友Sam_Ashwood说，马修的舞蹈是剧本里大纲写好的，还是在拍摄时基本即兴发挥的？我很喜欢这部剧，谢谢你们为我带来的无尽娱乐，现在我看了好多遍。
How many times that he's rewatched He's I think I've lost count years ago.
他重刷了多少次？我想他几年前就已经数不清了。
He says my memory is not as good as Ted's Let me we talked a little in the main episode about the choreography of that But a lot of people want to know about was that made up?
他说我的记性不如泰德。我们在正片里稍微聊过那段舞蹈的编排，但很多人想知道那是编出来的吗？
Did they make that up?
那是他们现编的吗？
Did they improvise that?
那是即兴发挥的吗？
It was choreographed to a T.
那是经过精确编排的。
I remember Jason being like, I don't dance.
我记得杰森当时说：“我不会跳舞。
I don't know how to do this.
我不知道该怎么做这动作。”
And I think her name is Kayla, I think, who is the choreographer of the episode is the woman that Barney was dancing with and never saw her face.
我想她叫凯拉吧，她是这一集的编舞，也就是巴尼一直在和她跳舞却始终没看到她脸的那个女生。
And turns out to be his cousin, spoilers.
结果证明那是他的表妹，剧透一下。
And so, yeah, so she did a great job.
所以，是的，她做得非常棒。
I'm sure in the script, we wrote a few things.
当然，在剧本里，我们确实写了一些东西。
I'm assuming we wrote Marshall does some robot.
我猜我们写了马修跳了一段机械舞。
We probably, like, named dropped a few weird little, like, 90s, 90s-era dance moves, but no, she'd all credits her into Jason.
我们可能还顺便抛出了几个奇怪的小动作，比如90年代风格的舞步，但不是的，所有的功劳都归功于她和杰森。
They worked really hard on that.
他们在这上面付出了极大的努力。
Pam, Prime and our director shot the hell out of that thing, and yeah, no, it was very down, down to the tiniest movement choreographer.
我们的导演帕姆把那段拍得棒极了，没错，那真的是精细到了每一个最小的动作，都是编排好的。
And Jason might have been scared, but you can tell from the little kind of space where he's dancing, he was having a blast.
杰森可能当时很害怕，但你可以从他跳舞的那一小块地方看出，他玩得嗨极了。
He got into it.
他完全投入进去了。
He definitely got into it.
他绝对是乐在其中。
But he was also on an unnamed substance, he think.
不过他当时好像也处于某种不知名的状态下。
Yes, he was.
是的，没错。
So Josh, broadening that out, how much they're, they're using, you know, ad live in improv a little, you know, generically here, but I mean, because people keep on wanting you guys to have made things up on the spot, you can talk a little bit about this, a bigger question.
所以乔什，把话题引申开来，大家在这里多多少少会有点泛泛地谈到即兴发挥，因为大家总是希望你们能当场即兴创作出一些东西，你可以稍微聊聊这个更大的问题。
What, what, what are you doing as an actor?
作为一个演员，你究竟在做些什么？
You have words on the page.
你们手头是有台词的。
Well, yeah.
对，没错。
I mean yours.
我是说，你的台词。
What's theirs?
那他们的呢？
It's worth considering this to, to, like the implication is Jason just started dancing And we caught that.
这其实很值得思考，因为这暗示着杰森当时只是开始跳舞，然后我们正好捕捉到了。
You can't do that.
你根本做不到这一点。
There's four cameras going.
现场有四台摄像机在运转。
There's extras who are being corralled and directed by the second AD.
还有临时演员被第二副导演组织和调度。
There's just so many moving parts and pieces.
有太多太多活动的部件和细节了。
Plus, it's a 22, 22 and a half minute story that has 40 to 60 scenes in it that are kind of choreographed and written just to be part of this functioning machine.
另外，这是一集22分钟、22分半钟的故事，里面有40到60个场景，它们都是为了成为这个高效运转的机器的一部分而被编排和写出来的。
I don't want to overuse that word, but it was like really tightly scripted.
我不想过度使用这个词，但它真的是一部剧本极其严密的剧。
What you could do is kind of at the end of a scene, there might be a little bit, there might have been a moment in rehearsal where you say, hey, would it be funny if Ted did this and you would negotiate it with, but there wasn't a ton of like, I think the idea is like a Judd Aptown movie or a Cassavetti's movie where they just kind of roll the camera and the actors just do lots of things.
你能做的，差不多就是在某个场景结束时，在排练的时候可能会出现一个瞬间，你说：“嘿，如果泰德这样做会不会很有趣？”然后你会商量着来，但并没有大量的那种——我觉得大家的印象就像是贾德·阿帕图的电影或者卡萨维蒂的电影那样，他们只是开着摄像机，演员们就即兴做各种各样的事情。
And maybe I'm robbing us of our own mystique or something, but how my mother was a really scripted show, that's why when people wanna get mad like around something Ted did, I was like, dude, I was contractually obligated to do those things, like this is my job, this is my job to be truthful and bring this stuff to life, and it wasn't my job to hijack the script and say, you know what I think should really happen because I write my own things, but Jason and I actually had this talk a bunch of times.
也许我这样说是在剥夺我们自己的神秘感或者别的什么，但《老爸老妈的浪漫史》是一部高度剧本化的剧，这就是为什么当人们对泰德做的一些事情感到生气时，我想说：“老兄，我合同上就规定了必须做那些事情，这是我的工作，我的工作就是保持真实并将这些内容呈现出来，把剧本劫持并说‘你知道我觉得真正该发生的是什么吗，因为我自己也写剧本’并不是我的工作。”但其实我和杰森多次讨论过这个。
We love writing scripts.
我们很喜欢写剧本。
We didn't think we'd be particularly good how I met your mother writers.
我们当时并不觉得自己能成为特别优秀的《老爸老妈的浪漫史》编剧。
Like it came from the minds of Craig and Carter and the writing staff.
因为那是出自克雷格、卡特和编剧团队的想法。
It was a very singular world that had its own rules and its own logic.
那是一个非常独特的世界，有它自己的规则和逻辑。
And we were just inside that, but we weren't the puppet masters.
我们只是身处其中，但我们并不是操纵木偶的人。
Yeah, I'm curious, Josh.
是的，我很想知道，乔什。
Does the fact that you are a writer and Jason too, Like, does that make it easier to show up and not need to write or change what's written and how I met your mother?
你和杰森都是作家，这个事实会不会让你们在片场时感觉更容易接受，而不需要去写或者修改《老爸老妈的浪漫史》里写好的东西？
Because Jason would always say to me, we come up, we pitch him some idea, we said we'd say, hey, we're going to do a big dance sequence and okay, awesome, you okay?
因为杰森总是对我说，当我们向他提出某个想法，对他说“嘿，我们要拍一整段舞蹈，在《绝妙好局》里，你觉得行吗？”
And he would always say, I'm your meet puppet.
他总是会说：“我是你们的肉偶。”
Go ahead.
“来吧。”
You just say, I'm your meet puppet.
你只管说“我是你们的肉偶”。
And he kind of meant it.
他基本上就是这个意思。
He's got to tell me what to do.
你们得告诉我该做什么。
We're doing it.
我们就照做。
And he would just comment.
他会这么说。
I don't share that with Jason.
我和杰森在这点上不太一样。
Like I know he felt more like put me where you want me, you know, like put me in coach.
我知道他更像是那种“把我放在你们想要的位置上，教练，派我上场吧”的心态。
I think he felt I was I was very curious about what you guys were up to like I said I always look forward to the script I always I was I was both a fan and I was I think I it's hard for me to watch things and not try to look under the hood and see a little bit like oh this is really smart how they're developing this character or this character's coming back and isn't that a funny callback like I'm interested in the mechanics but I also and I think I said this before I'm pretty clear about what I'm on set to do I was not there as a writer I was there to be the actor, and I had my actor had on.
我觉得他对你们在搞什么名堂非常好奇，就像我说的，我总是很期待剧本，我既是一个粉丝，同时我也觉得——让我看节目的时候不去试图一探究竟、看看幕后、不去想“哦，他们这样发展这个角色或者让这个角色回归真是太聪明了，这不是很搞笑的呼应吗”，这对我来说挺难的。我对剧本的机制很感兴趣，但同时，就像我之前说过的，我很清楚我到片场是来做什么的。我不是作为编剧去的，我是作为演员去的，我戴着演员的帽子。
But I think another kind of subtle subterating and part of me was like learning and observing and, and, and, yeah.
但我觉得我内心的另一种潜流和一部分自我其实是在学习、观察，然后把它们吸收进来。
Yeah, that's cool.
对，这很酷。
And, and you knew you were writing your own things.
而且你知道你自己在写别的东西。
Anyway, you got to be a writer in another, and other.
不管怎样，你在另一个地方是个编剧。
Exactly.
没错。
I got to, I got to be the master of that universe, and I didn't have to be in this one.
我是那个宇宙的主宰，在这个宇宙里我倒不必当主宰了。
And Jason too.
杰森也是。
And Craig also, you're now, at this point, you're all writing for Josh.
还有克雷格，此时此刻，你们所有人其实都是在为乔什写作。
So not to say that you're going, well, we'll kind of give him a thing and then he'll run with it.
这并不是说你们会想，“哦，我们给他安排个事儿，然后他自己去发挥吧”。
But you do know who you're writing for, which is different than writing a script and you don't know who you're going to cast it.
但你们确实很清楚你们在为谁写，这跟写一个剧本却不知道演员是谁是完全不同的。
You have to control that in a very different way.
你必须以一种非常不同的方式来掌控它。
If I give Josh this word, these lines in this moment, I know Josh Radner, and I want it to be a Josh Radner expression of what we are doing.
如果我在这一刻把这个词、这些台词给乔什，我了解乔什·拉德纳，我希望这是乔什·拉德纳对我们正在做的事情的一种表达。
You're already up to that at this point in episode five, right?
到了第五集的时候，你们就已经达到这种默契了吧？
Yeah, yeah, and that is the gift of long-form TV you you really get to know who you're writing for But you also want to find ways to surprise yourself and surprise them and try new things You want to also watch that and not assume you know exactly how they're supposed supposed to say it or supposed to do it And Jason was especially good at always surprising you with how he said and did things and Yeah, but what a gift to be able to write people you knew you like I felt some weeks you were you're seeing like, oh, I wonder if Josh or Jason or Kobe can do this, like, you throw it out there.
对，对，这就是长篇电视剧的馈赠，你真的会非常了解你是在为谁写剧本，但你同时也希望找到一些方法来惊艳自己、惊艳他们并尝试新事物。你还得注意这一点，不能想当然地以为你完全知道他们应该怎么说或者应该怎么做。而杰森尤其擅长用他说话和做事的方式不断给你带来惊喜，能为那些你认识并且喜欢的人写作，这真是一份厚礼，我有时会觉得，在某些周，你会看到“哦，不知道乔什、杰森或科比能不能做到这个”，然后你就会把这个想法抛出来。
Well, this dance sequence, for example, is a perfect example.
比如，这段舞蹈就是一个完美的例子。
But then there are other things that acquire a kind of power to them because you know, like when you wrote, right, right?
但除此之外，还有一些其他的事情会逐渐积聚起一种力量，因为你知道，就像你写的那样，对吧？
Like you knew that I, and you know, I remember in an early episode, I grabbed my heart, right?
就像你知道我——我记得在早期的一集里，我抓住了我的心脏，对吧？
And it became a very mose-be thing.
然后这就成了非常具有“老莫（Mosby）”风格的一个标志。
I think you guys actually started writing that in.
我想你们后来真的把这个写进剧本里了。
Oh, yeah, we did.
哦，对，我们确实这么做了。
And we, I think we refer to that one as the mose, but I guess lots of things could have but it is the dead heart grab.
而且我想我们把那个动作叫做“老莫式动作”，不过我想很多事情本来都可以这样，但那个捂心脏的动作确实成了标志。
Yeah, I mean, it's such a gift.
是的，我的意思是，这真是一份厚礼。
It's like an intimate connection and you don't get it, right?
这就像是一种亲密的联系，当你拍电影或者做其他事情时，你是体会不到的。
When you're shooting a movie or like you're doing other things, it's, you really get to know who you're writing for and that is great.
你真的能非常了解你是在为谁写作，这感觉太棒了。
And yet you also have to surprise them and yourself.
然而，你还得给他们和自己一些惊喜。
Josh, you answered many people's questions, by the way, who have asked throughout the episodes about the grabbing of the heart and is that you and is that written and what that is, so you have to know.
顺便说一句，乔希，你回答了许多观众在各集节目中问过的问题，关于抓心口这个动作，那是你吗，那是剧本里写的吗，还是怎么回事，所以你们一定想知道。
My memory of it is I did it first.
我的记忆是，我是第一个这么做的。
I did.
我确实是。
Yeah, that was me.
对，那是我。
And then you guys liked it.
然后你们就喜欢上了。
And then it just became a thing.
接着这成了一个标志性动作。
You may have done it in an audition for I might have.
你可能在试镜的时候就做过——我可能做过。
I mean, I'm like, I think we just took it.
我是说，我觉得我们就是直接采用了。
Yeah.
对。
I mean, that's like physical things you guys would do with where you're on inventions.
我是说，这就好比你们在即兴创作时会加入的一些形体动作。
Such an important part of who a character is, the physicality of that character.
角色的形体感是塑造角色至关重要的一部分。
Whether or not you're coming up with new lines all the time or not, you're inhabiting it in your body in ways that no writer could imagine.
不管你是不是一直在想出新台词，你都是在用身体去诠释角色，用任何编剧都想象不到的方式。
And so in that sense, you are constantly inventing material.
从这个意义上说，你一直在创造素材。
By the way, Josh, you said you worried about robbing us of your own mystique.
顺便说一句，乔希，你说你担心剥夺了我们对你原本的神秘感。
I would say that's the subtitle of this podcast.
我要说，这简直就是这个播客的副标题。
That is, that's all we're doing to find the curtain folks.
没错，这就是我们揭开幕布时在做的事，各位。
Here you go.
给你。
Vibesecting the mystique in real time.
实时解剖神秘感。
This represents many questions about props.
这就引出了许多关于道具的问题。
I think everyone is very inspired, Josh, by knowing the home of the Blue French horn there over your right shoulder.
乔希，我知道那把蓝法式圆号就放在你右肩膀后面的家里，大家都备受鼓舞。
So this was, be honest, Banana Shoe asks, be honest, who kept Barney's My Lars Silver club shirt, aka does Craig have a secret night shirt.
那么，说实话，Banana Shoe问：说实话，谁留下了巴尼的亮银紧身俱乐部衬衫，也就是克雷格是不是有一件秘密的夜行衬衫？
With all of these hero props or these special props, I mean, did most of them sit around for eight or nine years, and then it was a free for all.
对于所有这些核心道具或特殊道具，我是说，它们大多数都在仓库里放了八九年，然后大家就一拥而上抢光了吗？
Was it like, I mean, we learned from Courtney Kang coming up soon that she was inspired to, she was, it was hinted at that if she wrote something, she might be able to also walk away with the prop at the end.
是不是就像——我是说，我们从即将登场的考特尼·康那里了解到，她曾受到启发——暗示过如果她写了某段剧情，最后说不定也能把那个道具带走。
and she may or may not still have that at him and hold it up on camera in the episode.
而且她可能在这一集里真的把那个道具拿出来并在镜头前举着了，也可能没有。
It's possible, coming soon.
有可能，敬请期待。
Thanks, Trey.
谢谢，特雷。
So Craig, talk a little bit about what happens to the stuff.
所以克雷格，稍微聊聊这些东西最后都去哪儿了。
People want to know.
大家很想知道。
Yeah, I mean, you couldn't rob it during the production because God knows we were at Callbacky's show or we brought things back and back and back and back on that show.
对，我是说，在制作期间你可不能偷走它们，因为天知道我们当时在福克斯的片场，或者我们一遍又一遍、反反复复地把东西搬回那个节目里。
And so they had to keep stuff.
所以他们必须把东西留着。
They had to keep stuff.
他们必须把东西留着。
And then at the end, yeah, it was a little bit of a free fall.
然后到了最后，对，就有点像大抢购了。
Josh was like, I want the blue front chart.
乔希当时就说：“我要那只蓝法式圆号。”
You were just so clear, you're like, I want that one.
你当时态度超级明确，直接说：“我就要那个。”
That means the role to me.
那个对我来说代表了整部剧。
Yeah, there was no, there was no one else who would like claim to it.
对，没有别人，没有人会想要认领它。
I think oh my God, maybe maybe Kobe could have, but I think it is.
我想，天哪，也许柯比可能会要，但我觉得就是这样。
Yeah, yeah, that's the only other one you could have.
对，对，那是你唯一还能选的了。
Did someone take the jukebox?
有人拿走点唱机了吗？
Did Carter take the jukebox?
卡特把点唱机拿走了吗？
No, I don't think anybody took the jukebox.
不，我觉得没人拿走点唱机。
I have one of the two red hero booths in my apartment.
我的公寓里就放着那两张红色核心卡座长椅中的一张。
Oh wow.
哦，哇。
There's, if anyone's watching on YouTube, there is the purple giraffe right there over my shoulder.
如果有人在YouTube上观看的话，我的肩膀上方就能看到那只紫色的长颈鹿。
Yeah, we all took stuff.
对，我们都拿了东西。
Wardrobe things like that.
服装之类的东西。
Wardrobe was different.
服装就另当别论了。
Wardrobe kept stuff because sometimes we call it back, But I don't think anyone was ever going to call back that silver Mylar.
服装部门把东西留下了，因为有时我们会要求收回，但我认为不会有人要求收回那件银色亮片衬衫。
We are true.
确实如此。
I didn't take the Red Boots either, if anyone would say.
如果有人想知道的话，我也没拿那双红靴子。
If that's the real question, no.
如果这就是真正的问题的话，没有。
I didn't take the Red Boots.
我没拿红靴子。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我还为你写了一首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，HyperFixed播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接听听众的烦恼并努力为他们解决。
Problems like I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse We also solve non-car related problems if you have a problem not only will we fix it will expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place That's the hyperfixed podcast from radio topia find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixed pod dot com End of commercials back to show Henrik kiss mid-Juleus apologies Okay.
比如“我30岁了，在纽约开车感到害怕”或者“为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量”这类烦恼。我们也会解决与汽车无关的问题。如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。这就是来自Radiotopia的HyperFixed播客，你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它，或者访问hyperfixedpod.com。广告结束，回到节目。亨里克·基斯米德-朱利叶斯，抱歉。
How do you feel about the scene where Marshall and Lily jump out the window and how it affects the rest of the legitimacy of the story?
你怎么看马歇尔和莉莉跳窗的那场戏，以及它如何影响了整个故事的真实性？
How do you feel about this ridiculous decision and how it made the show different or unique?
你怎么看这个荒谬的决定，以及它如何让这部剧变得与众不同或独一无二？
We talked a little bit about that, but many people were concerned about this moment.
我们之前稍微聊过这个，但许多人对这个时刻感到担忧。
And in really through so many of these questions, it's also that they've all watched the show in a compressed way, right?
而且深入探究这些问题时会发现，这也是因为大家都是以一种紧凑的方式看剧的，对吧？
They've watched it quickly.
他们看得很仓促。
They've read one book that is the how I met your mother book.
他们读了一本名为《老爸老妈浪漫史》的书。
And when page two doesn't match with page 57, they see that as all one, whereas you're writing one page at a time barely, right?
而当第2页和第57页对不上时，他们觉得这是一个整体，而你们写剧本时其实是一页一页艰难创作出来的，对吧？
Right.
对的。
So, um, I guess talk a little bit about that, but also this This one notion of breaking reality the way Mr. Belvedere would not.
所以，嗯，我想请你稍微谈谈这个，还有这个打破现实的概念，就像《贝维尔德先生》不会做的那样。
We did Mr. Belvedere.
我们拍过《贝维尔德先生》。
That was a documentary.
那是一部纪录片。
That was technically a documentary.
那在技术上是一部纪录片。
It's a funny question because we never, we started playing with the unreliable narrator so early on.
这是一个有趣的问题，因为我们很早就开始运用不可靠的叙述者了。
The jump from the third floor was one of the first times we sort of left reality completely via the narrator.
从三楼跳下去，是我们首次通过叙述者彻底脱离现实的尝试之一。
And we talked about this in the episode within the proper podcast episode about Ocasam.
我们在正片的播客里也讨论过奥卡姆剃刀原理。
We were giddy.
我们当时兴奋极了。
我们高兴坏了。
We had this new toy of this narrator who could say, I don't remember the exact logistics, so maybe it was something like this.
我们有了这个新玩具——叙述者可以这么说：“我不记得具体细节了，所以大概是这样的。”
It's been 25 years since this story happened, and I loved that.
距离这个故事发生已经过去25年了，我太喜欢这样了。
That's how we all tell stories.
我们大家讲故事都是这样的。
Stuff that happened 25 years ago, your mind mixes things up, you embellish, you come up with transitions that didn't exist, timelines, intersects, things that happened two, three nights apart of the same night, I stand by it.
25年前发生的事情，你的大脑会把事情混淆，你会进行美化，你会编造出原本不存在的转折、时间线、交叉点，把明明相隔两三晚的事情说成是同一个晚上发生的，我坚持这种做法。
I completely stand by it.
我完全坚持这一点。
It is 100% the flavor of the show, and the way people tell stories and just the memories, right?
这百分之百就是这部剧的基调，也是人们讲故事的方式以及记忆的运作方式，对吧？
I also think that there's a, you don't even realize you're doing it, but you'll say like the night Uncle Marshall ate 10 tacos becomes like 37 tacos by the, by the, by the, by the second decade of telling the story, like, yeah.
我也觉得，你甚至都没有意识到自己在这么做，但当你讲到“当年马歇尔叔叔吃了10个塔可的那天晚上”，到了讲这个故事的第二个十年，就会变成吃了37个塔可，就像这样，对吧。
Everything gets, like you said, embellished or inflated, like, yeah, I remember I had an next girlfriend who, I told her some statistic, and it was like a hundred, It was like 10,000, right?
正如你所说，一切都被美化或夸大了，比如，对，我记得我有一个前女友，我告诉过她某个统计数据，大概是一百，大概是1万，对吧？
And then we were with some friends like a couple weeks later, and she re-told the statistics, because you know, I heard, and she said it was such authority that a million, like she used a million, and I was like, first of all, I told you that and it was 10,000.
然后几周后我们和一些朋友在一起，她重新讲了这个统计数据，因为你知道，我听到的，她用如此权威的语气说是一百万，就像她用了一百万一样，当时我就想，首先，我告诉过你那是1万。
Like she inflated it so outrageously, and it reminds you like, this is just a giant game of telephone.
她把它夸大得如此离谱，这让你想起，这其实就是一场巨大的传话游戏。
Like life is a huge game of telephone where it's like, you don't know where you are in the chain.
生活就像一场巨大的传话游戏，你甚至不知道自己处于这条链条的哪个位置。
like where how the information has been distorted or degraded by the time it got to you.
不知道信息传到你手里时已经被扭曲或退化成了什么样。
And it's telephone to your past self, the more time that says, there's all these different versions of you playing telephone with it.
而且这是对你过去的自己进行的传话，随着时间的推移，会有各种不同版本的你在和它玩传话游戏。
And you, you can get that 10,000 to a million all on your own.
而你可以凭一己之力把1万变成100万。
Yeah, it's that weird phenomenon.
对，就是那种奇怪的现象。
Like sometimes people tell a story so much they start thinking it happened to them.
有时人们把一个故事讲了太多次，以至于他们开始以为那是发生在他自己身上的事。
Yeah, it did not happen to them.
是的，那其实并没有发生在他身上。
It's just they've somehow like taken on and digested the story.
只是他们不知何故接受并消化了这个故事。
And they've told it so much that they've had a kind of visceral response to the story.
他们讲得太多了，以至于对这个故事产生了某种发自内心的反应。
and they become the protagonist of it, it's strange.
然后他们成了故事的主角，这很奇怪。
There's the great Malcolm Gladwell episode of his podcast called Free Brian Williams, which is all about what he thinks actually happened when Brian Williams said he experienced something in a helicopter and didn't, and it's Malcolm sort of re-telling him how mammary does that to you.
马尔科姆·格拉德威尔在他的播客里有一集很棒的节目叫《释放布莱恩·威廉姆斯》，主要讲的是他认为布莱恩·威廉姆斯说自己经历直升机事件时实际发生了什么，而马尔科姆实际上是在向他解释记忆是如何对你产生这种影响的。
I think Future Ted is going, I don't, there was no other exit from that apartment.
我觉得未来的泰德当时在想，我不觉得那个公寓有第二个出口。
And if Marshall simply walked out of this, Like why didn't she's like fancy part in it we're having he couldn't have got away with that.
如果马歇尔直接从那儿走出去——为什么她还要弄什么花哨的部分呢，我们正在经历的，他根本不可能逃得掉。
So there had to have another way.
所以必须有另一种方式。
Let's just say it was this.
我们就当它是这样的吧。
There's also an element of Ted has trapped his kids in this living room for a very long afternoon of stories.
这里还有一个因素，那就是泰德把他的孩子们困在这个起居室里，听他讲了一整个漫长下午的故事。
And he wants to be a good storyteller, right?
而且他想当个好的讲述者，对吧？
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like he's telling the story in the most kind of colorful, outrageous way.
就像他在用最生动、最夸张的方式讲故事。
I mean, he's essentially describing a prison break, right?
我的意思是，他本质上是在描述一次越狱，对吧？
Like it's a prison break.
就像这是一场越狱。
they're breaking out of this adult kind of like Duffy.
他们正在逃离这种成年人的、有点像达菲（Duffy）那样的束缚。
Yeah.
对。
And it's like it's a, it makes the story better.
这就好像，这让故事更精彩了。
Yeah.
对。
And reality Tim Robbins and Shawshank, he was just parole.
而现实中，蒂姆·罗宾斯在《肖申克的救赎》里，他其实只是假释。
None of that stuff actually happened.
那些事儿根本没发生过。
That's just how he tells the story.
那只是他讲故事的方式罢了。
Don't remember it that way.
可别按那个记忆去记。
Okay.
好吧。
So just this story, obviously ultimately is about something, is about growing up and and maturing and all of that.
所以这个故事，显然归根结底是关于某种东西，关于成长、成熟以及所有这些。
And so just a couple of comments on that.
所以关于这个有几个评论。
Then a question, Brian, for you go just says, no question here.
然后有个问题，布莱恩，给你的，go just说，这里没问题。
I love this episode.
我超喜欢这一集。
This episode completely changed my perspective about adulthood as the whole show did.
这一集彻底改变了我对成年期的看法，就像整部剧做的那样。
And uniquely show that growing up doesn't have to be scary and boring and hard.
它独特地展现了成长并不一定是可怕、枯燥和艰难的。
It's all up to where you want to go with your life.
这全取决于你想让生活走向何方。
It's a well-written proof and comfort.
这是一份文笔优美的证明与慰藉。
Thank you so much for the OK awesome masterpiece.
非常感谢这部完美无瑕的神作。
That is how I met your mother.
这就是《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
That's right.
没错。
Ross underscored W.A.
Ross 下划线 W.A. 说：
says, Lily, feels her and Marshall need to grow up and do grown-up stuff.
莉莉觉得她和马歇尔需要长大，做一些成年人该做的事。
Was that based on any real experience getting older and trying to toe the line between acting less silly but still having fun?
这是否有原型经验——变老，并试图在表现得没那么幼稚和依然保持乐趣之间走钢丝？
And finally, same genre, Val U.
最后，同一类型的，Val U.
It's a lot of the use.xx says, this rewatch is amazing.
It's a lot of the use.xx 说，这次重温太棒了。
I'm currently journaling about each episode in this podcast as gold.
我目前在为播客里的每一集写手记，这简直是宝藏。
It complements each other so well.
它们彼此相得益彰。
question is the line or a moment that you crossed and realized that you were already through the super joy of youth that had passed into the hell of adulthood.
问题是，有没有哪条线或哪个瞬间，让你跨过去并意识到，你已经走过了青春的极致喜悦，坠入了成年的地狱？
Jesus.
天哪。
Discuss.
大家讨论一下吧。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
Wow.
哇。
Well, I love it.
好吧，我喜欢。
You know what?
你知道吗？
The first comment reminded me of, um, I started making music with Ben Lee, who's this great Aussie songwriter and he did a post on Instagram that I thought was quite interesting.
第一条评论让我想起，嗯，我开始和本·李（Ben Lee）一起做音乐，他是位优秀的澳大利亚词曲作者，他在Instagram上发了一条动态，我觉得挺有意思的。
He said, I want to encourage more artists to be haters, and it was, you know, a provocative opening, but his point was he, like he has a huge hit song called Catch My Disease.
他说，我想鼓励更多艺术家当“黑子”，这是一个（你知道的）很有挑衅性的开场，但他的观点是，比如他有一首超级红的歌叫《Catch My Disease》。
And he just thought, there's so much like cynical, dark stuff out there right now.
他只是觉得，现在外面有太多愤世嫉俗、黑暗的东西了。
He just wanted to write like an optimistic BOP, right?
他只想写一首乐观抓耳的流行歌，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
And it became his biggest hit because he was annoyed at what he was hearing on the radio, you know?
而这成了他最火的歌，因为他对在收音机里听到的东西感到厌烦，你知道吗？
And he said, you can make different directions with your art in your life.
他说，你的艺术和生活可以有不同的方向。
It's just as informative to know what you don't like and what you don't want to be and the kind of art You you actually have an allergy to because they can redirect you towards something else as an antidote to that right yeah And I feel like when I looked out at the I don't know if we talked about this Craig but like I think we both had dads who wore suits weren't we talking about that like we were talking about that with Carter right yeah Yeah, like we had dads who wore suits my dad was a trial or he looked like like he just was so tired at the end of the day.
了解你不喜欢什么、你不想成为什么样的人，以及你实际上对哪种艺术“过敏”，这同样具有启发性，因为它们可以作为解药，引导你转向其他事物，对吧，是的。而且我觉得，当我望向——我不知道我们有没有聊过这个，克雷格，但我觉得我们俩的爸爸都穿西装，我们不是在聊这个吗？就像我们和卡特聊过这个，对吧，对，对，就像我们都有穿西装的爸爸，我爸爸是个出庭律师，或者他看起来——他一天下来就是累得不行。他身上有那种威利·洛曼（Willy Loman）式的精疲力竭感。我觉得我内心深处的某个部分在想，我这一生大概不想穿西装。
He just, it was, there was a kind of willy-loam in energy to him at the end of the day.
他身上有一种威利·洛曼式的精疲力竭感。
And I think something in me was like, I don't think I want to wear a suit in my life.
我觉得我内心深处的某个部分在想，我这一生大概不想穿西装。
Like, I don't want to put on that uniform.
就好像，我不想穿上那套制服。
And I think when you look out at the landscape of adulthood, when I was at, when I was at a vassar one summer, there were all these older actors, their 30s, 40s, 50s.
我想当你审视成年人的世界时，当我在一个夏天去瓦萨学院时，那里有各种年长的演员，三十多岁、四十多岁、五十多岁。
And man, they were drinking and having so much fun.
天哪，他们喝着酒，玩得那么开心。
And they were hooking up if they were not, you know, if they were single, maybe they weren't single, I don't know.
如果他们单身的话，他们就在约会，也许他们不是单身，我不知道。
But I look at them and I thought, oh my God, you don't have to lose your child like spirit.
但我看着他们想，天哪，你不需要失去你孩子般的精神。
You don't have to lose your appetite for fun and silliness, right?
你不需要失去对快乐和恶作剧的渴望，对吧？
And I found like being in show business, being an actor allowed me to have a life of play and spontaneity where I never, no one was ever like, well, you gotta, it's time, like you put on the tie, like stop having fun.
我发现身处娱乐圈、作为一个演员让我过上了一种充满玩乐和即兴的生活，从来没有人对我说，好吧，时间到了，你得系上领带，别再玩乐了。
start, you know, despairing because I was really afraid, much like Marshall, like I was afraid that adulthood would be just a drag or a Boris nor was it how I made your mother for a Boris nor.
开始，你知道的，感到绝望，因为我真的很害怕，就像马歇尔一样，我害怕成年生活只是一种无聊的苦差事，或者是像《老爸老妈浪漫史》里的那样。
A Boris nor yeah.
像个无聊透顶的苦差事，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
I was really afraid of it and I'm 50 years old and I have not found that to be the case, but I think I made certain decisions that that yeah, and I'm not by the way, we all have to make decisions financially and some of us have to put aside things that aren't working and go, I'm not saying that, but I do think with my friends, we still, even with you Craig, we still make the same jokes we were making 20 years ago, they're in the same ballpark of silliness.
我真的很害怕这一点，而现在我已经50岁了，我发现事实并非如此，但我认为我做出了一些决定，是的，顺便说一句，我们都在财务上做出决定，我们中的一些人不得不抛开那些行不通的事情然后说，我不是那个意思，但我确实认为和我的朋友们在一起，即使和你在一起，克雷格，我们仍然开着20年前开的那些玩笑，它们在恶作剧的同一个范围内。
So I don't think you have to, I don't think you have to wind and cheese your way into the grave.
所以我认为你不需要，我认为你不需要带着品酒和乳酪的心态走向坟墓。
I think that's right.
我想你是对的。
But I think when you're young, you think that is true, you think that's the qualification, a cost of adulthood.
但我认为当你年轻的时候，你认为那是真的，你认为那是成为成年人的资格和代价。
And I think when you're a kid and even in your 20s, you think that my daughter, Celia, just turned nine.
我想当你还是个孩子，甚至在你二十多岁的时候，你也会这么想，我女儿西莉亚刚刚满九岁。
And she's like this little sensitive soul.
她就像是个敏感的小灵魂。
She's like this little writer and artist and very, she just feels things rated deeply, but she's also very funny, very silly.
她就像是个小小作家和艺术家，非常，她对事物的感受极其深刻，但她也非常有趣，非常搞笑。
She turned nine and she just got a little sad at one point on her night's birthday and she said, like, I don't want to grow up.
她九岁生日那天，在某个时刻突然有点难过，她说，我不想长大。
It's so clear to me being a kid is the best part and that adulthood is going to be terrible.
对我来说，当孩子是最好的部分，而成年生活将会糟糕透顶，这真是太明显了。
She had this conception of like, adulthood being so serious and you won't be playful, you won't be joyful and silly anymore.
她对成年有着这样的概念，觉得成年是如此严肃，你将不再好玩，你将不再快乐和愚蠢。
And I said to Celia, I get it.
我对西莉亚说，我懂。
I remember thinking that stuff too, but just as an example, look at me, look at your father.
我也记得自己曾那样想过，但就拿我举个例子，看看我，看看你的父亲。
Do you think I'm a very serious person or am I silly and ridiculous all the time?
你觉得我是个很严肃的人，还是我一直都很傻气、很荒谬？
She's like, you're completely silly and ridiculous all the time, literally all the time.
她说，你整个人一直都很傻气、很荒谬，字面意义上的每一分每一秒。
You're literally drumming right now.
你现在真的在敲桌子呢。
Like, we can't even get you to be serious even like what she wants to be to be serious.
就像我们甚至无法让你认真起来，哪怕就像她希望的那样认真。
And I said, so like, I'm one of the adults in your life And I'm serious, very, very, very small percentage of the term.
然后我说，所以就像，我是你生命中的成年人之一，而我认真的时间只占极小极小极小的比例。
And she was like, okay, yeah.
然后她说，好吧，是的。
So I guess you are an example of a ridiculous adult from whom I have no respect.
所以我想你是一个荒谬的大人的例子，我对你没有任何尊重。
Great.
太棒了。
And I can grow up and be a clown too.
我长大后也可以当个小丑。
And I just, but she, it comforted her.
我只是，但这安慰了她。
But it was interesting to see that perception.
但看到这种看法很有趣。
And I think that's what we're, that continues in your 20s.
我认为这就是我们在二十多岁时继续经历的。
I remember feeling that way.
我记得当时有这种感觉。
I was like, my wife and I, she was, again, we went to college together.
我想，我和我妻子，她也是，我们一起上过大学。
We got engaged.
我们订婚了。
We were in the martial millie of our friend group.
我们当时正处于朋友圈的核心地带。
That's why we wrote that into the show.
这就是我们把它写进剧里的原因。
And I do remember moments where I felt like we had to, we were supposed to have the grownups now and our other friends Carter and other people weren't.
我确实记得有些时刻，我觉得我们必须，我们本该现在就成为大人的，而我们的其他朋友卡特和其他人却没有。
They were out there having more fun.
他们在外面玩得更开心。
And that is what this episode is wrestling with.
这就是本集所探讨的内容。
But I think it's interesting what you say, Josh, when you actually get there and you realize you can maintain your silliness and your play and your curiosity, that is a huge gift.
但我觉得乔斯你刚才说的话很有意思，当你真正到了那个阶段，你意识到你可以保持你的傻气、你的玩心和你的好奇心，这是一个巨大的礼物。
And I don't think you understand that when you're younger.
我不认为你在年轻时能理解这一点。
But I also think there's something, my wife and I, she's younger than me, but we have a phrase, I don't know if I've said this on the, but instead of saying the night is young, He said the night is old.
但我也觉得有一点，我和我妻子，她比我小，但我们有一句话，我不知道我有没有在节目里说过这个，我们不说“今夜还年轻”，而是说“今夜已老”。
Like it's time to wrap this up the night is old.
就像是该结束了，今夜已经老了。
And Alan, you can say that to us when we're going too long in the podcast.
艾伦，当我们在播客里聊得太久时，你可以对我们这么说。
So it's gonna be okay, okay.
所以没关系的，没关系的。
But when I would see my parents, like I'd be going out and my parents were getting into bed, right?
但每当我看到我的父母，比如我要出门而我的父母正准备上床睡觉，对吧？
Like you're going out at like 9.45, 10, or whatever when you're 18, 19.
就像你18、19岁的时候，大概9点45、10点左右出门。
And my parents were like, it was done.
而我父母觉得，一天的行程结束了。
Their day was over.
他们的一天已经过完了。
And I used to think it was so boring and sad that they were climbing into bed at 915, 930.
我以前觉得他们9点15、9点30就上床睡觉是一件极其无聊且悲伤的事。
If I can get myself in bed.
如果我现在能让自己上床睡觉。
Oh, it's glorious.
哦，那太棒了。
Glorious.
太棒了。
It's like you think, you know, I had a doctor years ago to tell me when you're younger, you're looking for ways to throw off energy because you have so much of it.
这就好像你觉得，你知道的，多年前有个医生告诉我，当你年轻的时候，你一直在寻找释放精力的方法，因为你有太多精力了。
And when you're older, you look for ways to conserve energy.
而当你老了，你在寻找保存精力的方法。
But the difference is when you're younger and you see adults who are conserving energy by going to sleep early and waking up early, you think that their life is over and they're in some sort of weird adult prison.
但不同的是，当你年轻时，看到成年人通过早睡早起去保存精力，你会觉得他们的人生已经结束了，他们被关在某种奇怪的成年人监狱里。
The truth is, they're psyched.
事实是，他们乐在其中。
They're psyched to go to sleep early and they're psyched to wake up early in the mornings or lovely.
他们很高兴能早睡，也很高兴能早起，清晨是非常美好的。
So yeah, you don't have the same life you had when you're a kid, but you do have, it's swapped out for fascinating, beautiful things and you don't have to lose your spontaneity and sense of play.
所以，是的，你可能没有了当孩子时的那种生活，但它被换成了迷人、美好的事物，你不需要失去你的随性与玩心。
Yeah, and I like, that's what Ted says essentially.
对，我喜欢，泰德基本上就是这么说的。
Like, I can't wait to be boring with you at the wine and cheese party, Marshall.
比如，马歇尔，我迫不及待想在红酒奶酪派对上和你一起变得无趣。
That's the great, generous thing that he says shouting because they all lost their hearing at the club, which is what makes it seem really funny, but it's, that's the theme of the episode.
那是他说过的一句很棒、很慷慨的话，他当时在大喊，因为他们在夜店里都把耳朵震聋了，这就是为什么这听起来非常搞笑，但这就是这集的主题。
I'll get there with you and I will sit there being boring and old with you because that's the goal.
我会陪着你到那一步，我会坐在那里，陪着你一起变得无趣和衰老，因为这才是最终的目标。
There's a line that actually, Josh, I quote from liberal arts all the time when I think about myself and I think about age, it's what Richard Jenkins says.
乔斯，其实有一句台词，每当我想起自己和年龄时，我总是会引用《自由艺术》里的台词，那是理查德·詹金斯（Richard Jenkins）说的。
I don't have the exact line.
我不记得原话了。
I can help you when you help me with it.
你帮我一下，我才能想起来。
You said line before I ruined it.
你刚说完“台词”我就给打断了。
Well, I think he says I've never felt not 19 right right that he said that's the secret something like that That the secret is that they don't tell you or whatever it is you always feel that young age now I don't know if that is true for all adults, you know my my father died very young in his 40s And he was an accountant he had the suitcase he had the suit and all of this and He felt certainly a much older 46 year old than I think I was I'm a little I'm a little boy you know, I definitely feel 19 and 18.
好吧，我想他说的是我从未觉得自己不是19岁，没错，没错，他说过，秘密就是，诸如此类的话，秘密在于他们不会告诉你，或者无论怎么说，你总是会觉得自己依然那么年轻。现在，我不知道这对所有成年人来说是不是真的，你知道的，我父亲去世得很早，四十多岁就去世了。他是一名会计，他有公文包，有西装，还有所有这些，而且他觉得自己作为一个46岁的人，比我当时想象的要老得多。我还是个小男孩，你知道的，我绝对觉得自己只有19岁和18岁。
And I don't feel a rush to grow up.
我并不急着长大。
And actually, for me, what's hard is taking on positions of leadership, where I think, me, I'm going to do this, but I'm 19.
实际上，对海岸我来说，难的是承担领导职务，因为我会想，我吗？我要做这个，可是我才19岁。
I can't, I can't do that.
我不能，我做不到。
Look at my haircut.
看看我的发型。
And I say, you're not, you're not 19.
然后我会对自己说，你已经不、不再是19岁了。
But that's always stayed with me that I don't know if he says it as a good thing or a bad thing.
但这这种感受一直伴随着我，我不知道他说这话时是觉得这是件好事还是坏事。
It's just sort of a truth.
这只是一种事实罢了。
I mean, I think he says it as a thing that is both true and mystifying because he says I look in the mirror and I don't see a 19 year old staring back at me.
我的意思是，我想他把这说成是一件既真实又让人感到迷惑的事，因为他说我照镜子时，看不到一个19岁的年轻人在回看着我。
I mean aging is one of the most trippy insane things we do because I remember I was talking to my friend Jamie who I met right out of NYU.
我的意思是，变老是我们所经历的最奇幻、最疯狂的事情之一，因为我还记得，我曾和杰米聊过天，我和他是在刚离开纽约大学时认识的。
He was just out of Northwestern and he and his friends had written this really brilliant musical and it was all about, it was basically like how I met my mother was all about like post-collegiate, first year out of college in New York City, being confused, being in love, being drunk and stupid.
他刚从西北大学毕业，他和他的朋友们写了一部非常精彩的音乐剧，内容完全是关于，基本上就像《老爸老妈浪漫史》那样，讲的是大学毕业后在纽约市的第一年，感到迷茫、陷入爱河、喝醉了酒又傻里傻气的经历。
But it was beautiful.
但那部剧很美。
And I reconnected with him a couple years ago and we're really back in each other's lives in a really great way.
几年前我和他重新取得了联系，我们又以一种非常美好的方式回到了彼此的生活中。
And I said, and he's got two daughters now, right?
我说，他现在有两个女儿了，对吧？
And I was like, isn't aging insane?
我就说，变老不是很疯狂吗？
And he said, yeah, I said, especially for us, our entire brand was that we were young.
他说，是的，我说，尤其是对我们来说，我们的整个金字招牌就是我们还年轻。
Like that was our whole thing.
这就像是我们的全部标志。
You know, at some point in New York City, we're like, we're the young people.
你知道，在纽约市的某个时候，我们会觉得，我们才是年轻人。
Like, where's the new crop?
就像在想，新的一批年轻人在哪儿？
And suddenly you realize, like, I did this show rise a couple of years ago on NBC where I played this public school teacher and they're all these high school kids, you know?
突然之间你意识到，比如，几年前我在NBC做过一档叫《非凡戏剧》的节目，我在里面饰演一位公立学校的老师，里面有一群高中生，你知道吗？
And they looked at me, because they had grown up watching how I met your mother and they'd seen other stuff I had done.
他们看着我，因为他们是看着《老爸老妈浪漫史》长大的，而且他们也看过我演的其他作品。
I was suddenly like the elder in the room and that, that happens very suddenly.
我突然成了房间里的老前辈，而这，发生得非常突然。
It's like, one day you're the like the fresh eye kind of apprentice.
这就好像，有一天你还是那个眼神清澈、初出茅庐的学徒。
I mean, it's kind of cool watching like the pit.
我的意思是，看着像《急诊室的故事》这样的剧挺酷的。
Are you watching the pit?
你在看《急诊室的故事》吗？
know on HBO or max like Noah Wiley is this like seasoned veteran emergency director but in our memory in our collective memory he's like the quiet-eyed young guy first day on the job and now he's the one taking through the youngsters through their job you know teaching them the ropes so that just happens naturally I mean I I both I think I'm fortunate in that I both like being a student and a mentor like I like them both and I still consider myself a student in a lot of ways but I also I like giving advice when and I have something to offer, you know?
你知道在HBO或Max上，诺亚·怀尔（Noah Wiley）饰演一个经验丰富的资深急诊室主任，但在我们的记忆中，在我们的集体记忆里，他还是那个眼神平静、刚上班第一天的年轻小伙，而现在，他成了那个带年轻人熟悉工作的人，你知道的，教他们业务诀窍，所以这一切都是自然发生的。我的意思是，我既，我觉得自己很幸运，因为我既喜欢当学生，也喜欢当导师，这两者我都喜欢，在很多方面我仍然认为自己是个学生，但我也，我喜欢在有机会且自己有东西可分享时给出建议，你知道吗？
Well, I think we're talking about what future Ted is essentially trying to do with his children, writ large across the entire series in some ways, which is cool.
嗯，我想我们在讨论的是，未来的泰德基本上试图对他的孩子们做的事，在某种程度上贯穿了整个系列剧，这真的很酷。
Before we close here, we actually have an audio question from Maya Rupert, a friend of the show, Craig, do you wanna tell us a little bit about who Maya is?
在我们结束节目之前，我们其实收到了玛雅·鲁珀特（Maya Rupert）的一条语音提问，她是本节目的老朋友，克雷格，你想跟我们简单介绍一下玛雅是谁吗？
Josh and I are both friendly with Maya, but Josh, you've met her in real life and I haven't, right?
我和乔斯都和玛雅很熟，但乔斯，你在现实生活中见过她，而我没有，对吧？
I think maybe you should talk about it.
我想也许你应该谈谈她。
I have, she's come to some of my shows.
我见过，她来看过我的几场演出。
She came to my play at the public.
她来看过我在Public剧院的戏剧。
She's lovely.
她人非常好。
I mean, she works in Democratic politics at like the highest levels.
我的意思是，她从事民主党政治工作，而且是在最高层。
Yeah.
对。
She's incredibly thoughtful and sincere and motivated, but she also loves music and she loves comedy and she loves how I met your mother and she's just been really wonderful to both of us.
她极其体贴、真诚且充满动力，但她也热爱音乐，热爱喜剧，热爱《老爸老妈浪漫史》，对我们俩真的都非常好。
Yeah, really smart, really cool, really brilliant person.
是的，非常聪明，非常酷，非常杰出的人。
The kind of person you're just psyched as a fan of the thing you did, you know?
那种会让你作为你所做的事情的粉丝而感到由衷高兴的人，你知道的？
whether it's your music or your show, she's the best.
无论是你的音乐还是你的节目，她都是最棒的。
All right, well, we have the rare audio question for this general question.
好吧，那么，对于这个常规问题，我们有一个难得的语音提问。
Here we go.
我们开始吧。
Hey, Craig and Josh, it is my Rupert, huge fan of the podcast.
嘿，克雷格和乔斯，我是玛雅·鲁珀特，我是这个播客的超级粉丝。
And as you know, huge fan of the two of you as well.
如你们所知，我也是你们俩的超级粉丝。
Okay, awesome, has a huge place in my heart.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》，在我心中占据着极其重要的地位。
I'm writing a book, it will be out in early 2026 and one of the sort of central metaphors that I use in the book is actually derived from this episode.
我正在写一本书，将于2026年初出版，我在书中使用的核心隐喻之一，实际上就源自这一集。
I have something I call my okay awesome list, which is basically a list of things that I don't like, but I don't want to admit, because they are supposed to be awesome.
我有一个被称为“好吧真棒”清单的东西，这基本上是一张列着我不喜欢、但又不想承认的事物的清单，因为这些事本该是“很棒”的。
And anytime someone suggested one of these things to me, I would, as like my own little inside joke with myself, I would say okay awesome, and then figure out a way to get out of it later.
每当有人向我推荐其中一件事时，我就会像对自己开的一个小玩笑一样，说一句“好吧真棒”，然后想办法在事后推脱掉。
So my question is, what are on your okay, awesome lists?
所以我的问题是，在你们的“好吧真棒”清单上都有什么？
Were they the things that Ted and Coach Echel were discussing?
是泰德和埃克尔教练讨论过的那几样吗？
Or do you have other ones?
还是你们有其他的？
I would love to hear.
我很想听听看。
That's a great question.
这是个好问题。
I love that question.
我喜欢这个问。
Definitely some of those, I think the one I pitched really hard was parades.
绝对有其中的一些，我想我极力推荐的一个是游行。
I think that might have been mine because I really, that Ted says twice in the list is that I know I really hate parades.
我想那可能是我的，因为我真的，泰德在清单里说了两次，我知道我真的很讨厌游行。
I thought it might have been mine.
我以为那可能是我的。
I've never been on a cruise, but they don't seem great.
我从来没坐过邮轮，但它们听起来似乎不怎么样。
What are the other ones that they said?
他们还说过哪些？
The Super Bowl can be anti-climactic.
超级碗可能会让人觉得虎头蛇尾。
New Year's Eve is almost in the episode two, which I thought was a nice little call forward.
新年夜也出现在这一集里，我觉得这是一个很好的前后呼应的小彩蛋。
You know, I had a thing about certain like very fancy foods.
你知道的，我对某些非常高级的食物有点看法。
I actually find disgusting.
我其实觉得很恶心。
Yeah.
对。
I mean, it's okay for ethical reasons to hate this, but I think Fla Gra is one of the worst tastes I've ever had.
我的意思是，出于伦理原因讨厌这个是可以理解的，但我认为鹅肝是我吃过的最难吃的味道之一。
And also like bone marrow, like you know, in the in the thing, like get that away from me.
还有像骨髓，你知道的，在那个，呃，离我远点。
Yeah.
对。
My my food version of that is not a fancy food, but just raisins.
我对食物的这种版本不是高级料理，而只是葡萄干。
I think everything is made slightly worse by putting raisins in there.
我觉得任何东西只要加了葡萄干，都会变得稍微难吃一点。
Yeah.
对。
I would say love it.
我会说，我懂。
I hate raisins in things, but I don't mind a little red.
我讨厌食物里有葡萄干，但我不介意有一点红色的。
Okay.
好吧。
I'll eat the red thing.
红色的东西我会吃的。
I'll be honest.
说实话。
I'll eat the red thing too.
红色的东西我也会吃的。
Just don't put them in.
只是别把它们加进去。
I have a I have a weird one and it's literally the main source of tension in my marriage.
我有一个，我有一个很奇怪的怪癖，这简直是我婚姻中产生矛盾的主要根源。
Oh my God, Maya, you've gotten this in precarious.
天哪，玛雅，你把这事搞得悬念重重了。
She would be.
她确实会。
Dana is a legitimate fan of television in a way that I simply am not.
达娜是一个真正的电视迷，而我远算不上。
And I know it's strange because I've made my living mostly on it.
我知道这很奇怪，因为我主要靠它谋生。
Yeah.
对。
I like making it.
我喜欢制作它。
I don't have the patience and stamina to sit down and binge.
但我没有耐心和精力坐下来疯狂追剧。
And so she really wants me to just sit there with her and that's how she decompresses after it.
所以她真的很希望我就坐在她身边陪着她，那是她看完剧之后的解压方式。
That's her, you know, and she doesn't glaze out her zone out.
那是她的方式，你知道的，她不会放空或走神。
She can really be present with me, but we've struck up a compromise where I will sit next to her and maybe I'll be on my computer doing a cross-repelling and I'll kind of half-watch the show.
她真的能专心地陪着我，不过我们达成了一种妥协：我会坐在她旁边，可能在电脑上做点交叉排练之类的事情，然后顺便半心半意地看一眼节目。
But she really feels like she wants more.
但她真的觉得她想要更多。
And I can't, for some reason, I can't do TV the way that most people do TV, which is like, I love this show.
而我不知道为什么，我无法像大多数人那样看电视——那种觉得“我太喜欢这个节目了”。
I'm going to keep watching them.
“我要一直看下去”。
I'll watch a lot of episodes.
“我要连看好多集”。
That's really funny.
那真的太逗了。
We watched out of lessons and I watched it all for in a day and boy, she's proud of me.
我们看完了《青春期》，我一天就把它们全看完了，天哪，她为我骄傲呢。
But so she's not watching like dumb stuff, Adelaide doesn't seem like she has good taste.
不过她看的不是那种很烂的东西，阿德莱德看起来品味挺不错的。
She watches good stuff.
她看的都是好东西。
There's one show that I will not name that is absolute garbage.
有一个节目我不会点名，简直是彻头彻尾的垃圾。
My smile will text you that on the side, but you know what?
回头我私信发你，但你知道吗？
I almost enjoy that one more because I can make fun of the show over her shoulder and I make her laugh because she knows, you know, she's not thinking she's watching something great.
我反而更喜欢看那个，因为我可以在她耳边吐槽那个节目，还能把她逗笑，因为她自己也知道，她可没觉得自己是在看什么好作品。
That's so funny.
太搞笑了。
Yeah.
对。
the circus.
就像马戏团一样。
She busted me.
她抓包我了。
She says, I feel like I have to defend myself.
她说，我觉得我得为自己辩解一下。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
I just said that.
我刚才就这么说的。
I said that.
我就是这么说的。
She said it was the best day of her life when I watched 40 episodes of adolescence.
她说当我看了40集《青春期》的时候，那是她生命中最美好的一天。
I love that she knew to what a spidey sense went off in Jordan when you said, okay, the biggest issue in my marriage is and she just came from the other room.
我喜欢她那种敏锐度，乔丹，当你说“好吧，我婚姻中最大的问题是”时，她的蜘蛛感应就立刻触发了，然后她就从隔壁房间过来了。
He said a spidey sense went off with you and you just like came from the other room.
你说你的蜘蛛感应触发了，然后你就像这样从隔壁房间走过来。
I'm knowing we were stuck this.
我知道我们被这个卡住了。
Yeah, I was talking about, yeah, I won't name the show, because there's nice people on it.
对，我刚才在说，对，我不会说出那个节目的名字，因为里面有好人。
She loves it.
她超爱它。
Oh my god, yeah, don't name the show.
哦天哪，对，别说出那个节目的名字。
I would add one other thing for me, personally, tropical beach vacations, whenever I try to go, like to wear a resort or somewhere, like to swim straight.
我个人还要补充一点，热带海滩度假，每当我尝试去的时候，比如去度假村或者某个地方，想直接去游泳。
My wife and I went on one on a day one, we stepped on sea urchins and became incapacitated, like we could not walk for several days, we got like hundreds of sea urchins, yeah, That just always goes wrong from me.
我和我太太去过一次，第一天我们踩到了海胆，然后就动不了了，好几天都走不动路，扎了大概上百个海胆刺，对，那对我来说总是状况百出。
Jordan, I have tried.
乔丹，我试过了。
We keep trying beaches and we just finally looked at each other and we're like, we don't like it.
我们一直尝试去海滩，最后我们看着彼此，心想：我们其实并不喜欢。
It's just when I'm Irish.
这只是因为我是个爱尔兰人。
I just want to be in the rain and it's green like we're mountains and lakes, people.
我只想待在雨里，这里像山脉和湖泊一样翠绿，大家懂的。
Yeah.
对。
Me too.
我也是。
And cities.
还有城市。
I like cities.
我喜欢城市。
Anyway.
总之。
Maya, we are honored, honored that you're putting that in the book and everybody look up from Maya's book.
玛雅，我们深感荣幸，能把这些写进书里，大家都要去读读玛雅的书。
She's a really, really smart and cool person and writer and yeah, so thank you Maya.
她是一个非常非常聪明、酷炫的人和作家，所以，谢谢你，玛雅。
Well, the night is old folks.
好了，夜还年轻呢，各位。
The night is old.
夜还年轻。
There's another episode of General Questions.
还有另一期“常见问题”。
General Questions?
常见问题？
Questions.
问题。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
Keep sending them in through Instagram and we will keep on trying to answer them.
请继续通过Instagram发给我们，我们会继续尝试解答。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我是如何成为你母亲的》由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作，联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡（Doug Matica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, artwork by John Marrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是“蓝色之点”工作室（Point of Blue Studios）的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves），封面设计由约翰·马罗（John Marrow）完成。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上订阅、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》（NYC），特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳兹（Elliott Connards）。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的Substack邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目重要的组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' Muse Letters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society also on Substack.
在Substack上订阅乔什·拉德纳的缪斯信（Muse Letters），在 CraigThomasRider.com 阅读克雷格·托马斯的已发表散文，你也可以同样在Substack上订阅我的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Father Society）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何为本节目持续筹集先天性心脏病研究资金的公益活动出一份力，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
本期节目的制作得到了后院创投（backyard ventures）的大力支持，营销由丁克传媒（Tink Media）提供。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上会跳舞。
The real question.
真正的问题是。
It just hit me.
我突然意识到了。
Am I in love with you?
我是爱上了你？
Or just New York City?
还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？